[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity earlier today former president
Donald Trump waived his right to an
in-person arraignment and pled not
guilty to the charges in Georgia that
means Trump has now officially pled not
guilty to all 91 alleged crimes in all
four jurisdictions
here now with reaction is Trump legal
spokeswoman Alina Hava a lead up thanks
for being here I feel like we're gonna
have update after update after update
after update because this is what
they've done this is what they've set
into motion give us an update on what
this means as it pertains to the case
down in Atlanta on what the Trump legal
strategy is
I think uh it's not surprising that he
pled today not guilty obviously he
waived for his right to go in for an
arraignment in person because why give
them more of a media frenzy we don't
need that so you know from here we
actually get to litigate the case which
as an attorney I look forward to I know
our legal team does as well to getting
to take our own turn at looking at all
of the information and our own turn to
put our our side out which is something
that everybody needs to remember has not
happened as of yet for indictments are
simply that an indictment which is just
one-sided BS for lack of a better word
on their political scheme to interfere
with the leading candidate for president
so Elena this is all ridiculous it's all
a circus it's all meant to interfere
inside the timeline in the election
process that that's a given so these
questions sort of come with that uh that
sense of How It's but if you're planning
for Georgia
um the the DC uh uh
timeline was just set for March 4th as
you know the day before super Tuesday uh
much sooner than your team had
anticipated what do you anticipate for a
timeline down in Atlanta like how
quickly are they going to try to push
this in your sense and how will you push
back
let's be clear the Jack Smiths and the
Fannie willises and the D.A Braggs and
the Leticia James if they could have it
their way they would have all trials the
same week uh what it's unrealistic it's
ridiculous and it's obvious so what I
think is happening is the judges are
going to have to fight it amongst
themselves you cannot have one defendant
on multiple cases but if you do look at
the Timeline like you mentioned every
single event every single event from the
indictment to the rush grand jury years
after the events took place when they
didn't need to rush it they could have
had it two years ago every single thing
says very clearly Joe Biden doesn't know
what he's doing in office so let's
distract America so that all we talk
about is President Trump and these
hoaxes and that's really all they are so
what are they we're going to obviously
argue that it's impossible for one
person to be in four different places
we're going to argue that this is
election interference and then we're
going to take a look at each individual
person and say you ran for office based
on the fact that you said you were going
to get Trump and so did you and so did
you and now we need our Constitution and
due process to step in and do its part
and if we don't have Fair judges
unfortunately we're not going to get
that so we have a great team I love our
legal team right now I feel strong the
president feels strong and we're going
to take each one head on
it is amazing uh when you look at Hunter
Biden problem indictment Hunter Biden
problem add charges to indictment Hunter
Biden problem indictment again uh when
do we set the trial date uh Iowa
caucuses how about we do it the day
before super Tuesday I've never seen
anything like it of course it's totally
unprecedented and the way you put it
together
um it is election interference and it
keeps us updated on what you're seeing
appreciate your time Alina Haba thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else